this week I'm talking about Easter eggs
and the fact our children have eaten
thousands since they hit the shops in
January an obese Britain is always an
excuse to eat more sweets than chocolate
Easter Christmas Halloween Valentine's
Day and while we can't stop the shops
from selling it it's a parent's duty to
stop their kids eating it but many don't
because they're lazy and selfish and
don't care that obesity causes heart
attacks limb amputations diabetes and
cancer we're in the midst of a child
obesity crisis for goodness sake it's
time parents accepted that what goes
into their kids mouth is 100% their
responsibility and I'm sick of hearing
that parents of fat kids or victims
themselves know their abusers who are
deliberately harming their child's
health if a child was being battered at
home social services would be there in a
flash so why ignore parents who are
literally feeding their kids to an early
death what a child wants is a world away
from what it needs and what all kids
need our parents who love them enough to
say no impossible to get such
inflammatory language into a
conversation about Easter eggs but Carol
you've haven't disappointed right let me
paint a picture you've got heavy kid
right who is morbidly obese mum and dad
clearly had no idea about healthy diet
and they allow the child to gorge on
chocolate and chips and fizzy drinks do
you want that job taking interstate
control now what I want is I want that
someone from maybe surface services come
and talk to them about it and they tried
coming up they still closed well you
know the intimately word you doesn't
usually go into social connectiveness
let me ask you a question if a child was
being why don't you answer my phone well
I will and if the child is that fat and
it's it's health is in danger maybe for
a while because they're just a clerical
you would have a state take a fat child
away from mum and dad if it was a
morbidly a bit
you know ask me the question let me
answer it for you if it wasn't morbidly
obese child whose health was immediate
danger why wouldn't you as I said in the
intro if you have a parent who's
battering a child who's hitting a child
that's why she's not actually why would
you not go
because the child is in danger either
way that's why I'm so just to clarify
it's on the Senate as a passive child
30% of kids in this country are
overweight or obese and their head and
some of the illnesses that I said
they're heading for it's not 10 to 20
years off their lives and I don't buy
the argument that parents don't know
about a healthy eating we're drowning in
information about have to be pushed me
into saying yes and parents I said have
to be seen by most parents for most
parents that would be enough but surely
society ie government the rest of you
should be looking at ways we can reduce
we can reduce the this week the
government puts that initiatives and
people ignored people don't care about
obesity in this country anymore they
just keep eating
I genuinely do think that the the people
that are flogging these eggs have got a
little bit of answer for yeah and you
know you've only just you you've only
just sort like advertised the birth of
Christ you're advertising his death you
know literally moving days aren't you
sometimes you not me though the cracking
on about Easter before boxing though
sometimes when I was a kid okay you got
an egg similar to this one right it
wasn't very big and it probably had
lasted quite a long time and you got a
little bit after tea every day now
nowadays this large Cadbury's egg has 17
days worth of sugar that's outstanding
and not only that kind of eggs get
rabbits smaller yeah not very good
rabbits well I can't get rabbits all
right okay all that clobber and it's
just outrageous that these people that
are selling it
I just permanently thrown out you and of
course kids are gonna go oh we gonna mix
it always was I mean for years I mean I
do deny the Easter egg hunt to my kids
every year ten or twelve small eggs
hidden somewhere I used to hide them in
places they could never find them which
is the dog used to fix
I mean I'd honestly don't think we
should get over this oppressive there is
a problem in this isn't there's a
problem meaning I remember going to
Disney World in America with my son and
saying and we were so shocked by how big
everybody was we were saying we
a competition for who could find the
biggest person there he is a young lad
rushed up to some woman and said dad dad
do you think when you see a child
holding the hand of a mom or a dad a big
child right do you think that that's
down to bad Parrington what do you think
that is down to ice a mix of things yet
bad parenting and probably not enough
exercise possibly he she goes to a
school where there's no playing fields
because it started under mrs. Thatcher
they're caring on Plex selling off
playing fields at a ridiculous and
criminal rate so it's a whole whole what
do you think we should do about it
educate educate educate it's not working
I do I think I think it's what I I had
excellent parenting parents who
completely understood healthy diet gave
me great food at home I was the fat kid
I went out and found ways of getting
chocolate I wanted it you know and I I
loved the ads I bought into em annoys
the teenager you know I remember these
women in the bar for the bar a huge bar
of chocolate and then it was like you
have to have a bar of chocolate while
you're in the bath I was like a sponge
soaking up all this nonsense I actually
think that these comfortable turn the
corner yes it was when I got old enough
to take responsibility for my own health
probably my early 20s to be honest I
started exercising and thinking more
about what and I actually add to get
quite radical I became a raw food vegan
and that's how fast the other extreme I
needed to go to correct all of the
condition I had I think that these
companies in a way they're grooming us
if you go into a supermarket with a
child you will still see aisles a
brightly colored beautifully wrapped
sugar by the checkout by the toy
dragster Easter eggs I still buy the
Cheshire I can tell my students a day
and I think Easter used to be a
religious festival no I used to be a
really just Christian festival I have a
huge respect for religious festivals of
all faiths these Christian festivals
Christmas and Easter in particular have
become exploits for private companies to
sell sugar to
and there's always something like your
kids it's a good cause he's the bloke
who makes the up parking chocolate so
they're trying to sell what is it the
point is there is chocolate that isn't
full of sugar yes and there was a piece
in the paper this week saying if you
have two squares and 50 to 70% dark
chocolate it's actually good for you if
you can't afford that so let's see what
the manufacturers say Mars there are
seasonal products for gifting and
sharing we clearly display the
nutritional information and recommended
portion size on the packaging Nestle
chocolate eggs are an Easter tradition
ask contain clear nutritional
information and lastly Cadbury we
encourage our consumers to be treat wise
and our larger eggs are intended for
gifting and sharing and are resealable
we also have a great selection of
smaller extra children after what are
you going to do to make sure your
daughter doesn't perhaps have weight
issues or chocolate issues or sweet
issues you try and counter the forces
that are out there by giving them a
fruit at home encouraging lots of
exercise teaching them to be responsible
for thinking about what they eat but the
realities you feel like you are
constantly battling against this huge
wave of conditioning they're getting on
TV and this is my argument you are
battling and it is a parent's
responsibility to not allow their
children to get overweight but they
failed
and for a lot of young women I think
there is low self-esteem as puberty
there are lots of reasons why young
people seek out sugar I'm just saying as
a parent who's trying to do the right
thing and succeeding as far as I know
it's not that helpful but you're
constantly battling against everything
else
anyway she won't get one that size and
she will only get one and she will have
to make it last by having a little bit
every getting to ten there was there's a
kid near me she gets ten every year
now that's each one of those two
seventy-five percent of an adult's
calories in the day and they eat them
over three or four day that is not why
I'm gonna give my daughter one but
she'll probably get one at school her
friends will give them out in the
playground on the day they break up you
know it can be fixed she's gonna do an
Easter count where they'll probably give
them out a break time it's hard to
control and I think that we do need to
like Ray was they have a war holistic
approach to why we have these social
values that are pushing sugar on our
kids I think the problem in society now
is we have a society that doesn't care
about obesity the government is choking
out initiatives every other day and we
just ignore them as a society at large
we ignore them the unsavory truth about
the Easter Egg business but we move on
it was a summer of long hot nights high
hopes and unexpected celebrations as
England reached the climax of their
World Cup bid during the tournament in
Russia but it seems that one player
really knew how to celebrate in style
defender and Lester ace Harry McGuire
and his fiancee fern welcomed a little
bundle of joy into their lives this week
and as the England team didn't fail to
miss baby Lily was born exactly nine
months after England's first ever World
Cup penalty shootout win no prizes for
guessing what you're up to after the win
a Hazar
and that's why Harry McGuire you're our
straight shooter of the week
congratulations you'll be happy with
that
well of course at one time I mean some
World Cups the wives and partners
haven't been allowed anywhere near the
blokes and it put the thinking in a
sense as is it's better to have yeah
yeah but this time we had a much more
thinking manager who decided that
actually they would be better off if
their wives were allowed certain visits
it's still that rule about you can't do
it before a match well I don't know how
you police that